So, what we're making today is a shrimp
and chermoula sauce over a bed of couscous, Drew.
So what you have here is some chicken stock.
You can use plain water as well,
and we're gonna pour in that couscous,
give it a good stir, just like Drew did.
I'm gonna pop in some salt
and then pop the cover in and turn off, forget about it.
So now we're gonna move on to the chermoula sauce.
It is this wonderful North African herb sauce.
You basically have everything, I promise you,
in your pantry to make this.
I'm gonna move that.
So we have chopped cilantro and chopped parsley,
a little bit of coriander, cumin, red chili flake,
the pantry's just given us today, smoked paprika,
hot paprika, and a little bit of salt.
We mix that all together.
I love a Hungarian paprika too.
And then we're gonna micro zest a little bit.
One garlic, one garlic clove.
Wow, that really zested super quickly.
We're gonna pour in that olive of oil, Drew.
I'm gonna give this a mix.
(Drew grumbling)
You got this.
Keep on mixing.
Okay. Ready?
And this is really, this sauce guys is amazing.
It's like punchy, it's verdant,
it's like just really, really beautiful.
We're done.
And it's super addictive.
So you're gonna mix that in.
The last two things is your citrus.
And we're gonna add that in a little bit.
I only like to add my citrus to my chermoula
right before when I'm gonna use it, basically.
Is that because it'll like cook, ferment-
It'll basically start to discolor the sauce a little bit.
And I really wanna make sure
that it's as bright and beautiful as possible.
So now we have a pan, about a tablespoon of olive oil.
You got your peeled and deveined shrimp.
And I am a good peeler and deveiner.
If anybody needs-
You're so quick with your-
Thank you.
I really pride myself.
I mean, it's amazing.
So give them a shake.
You need peeling and deveining, give it to me!
I'll do it.
Give your shrimp a shake
so that it's all on one layer.
And then we're gonna season it, Drew, with salt
and a little bit of cracked black pepper.
And so just let that shrimp go.
So what we're gonna do here.
So this is kind of a specialty pantry item.
It's called preserved lemon.
If you don't have it, you can use regular lemon,
but it's actually a really easy and fun
kitchen project to make.
Basically you take a lemon, you put it in a jar,
you put it in a salt solution, you make some slits.
And the lemon basically starts to essentially pickle itself
which is really nice.
And then you can add it into all your sauces.
We have it here in our shrimp.
It's wonderful in salads as well.
And then Drew, right on cue we're gonna flip that shrimp.
Flip that shrimp.
And as you can see,
it's starting to get-
I got one shrimp that's
really nice pink.
Having a real hard time.
(laughs) That color is really good.
Yeah, this color is perfect.
It smells really great.
And you really don't wanna overcook your shrimp.
People don't like to overcook a shrimp.
I don't mind.
I like my fish and meat a little tough, or I like it raw.
I'm an extremist. I don't know what to say.
(Pilar laughs)
All right, how long we have?
All, right.
So that's probably-
Three more minutes!
Three more minutes?
Oh, perfect.
We got plenty of time.
What!
So shrimp is really great for when you are
like doing a quick and easy dish.
This sauce, we're gonna use it two ways.
So we're only gonna put half in.
Half!
And the reason Drew,
so you can use it as a marinade for like fish and for meat.
But the reason why I don't like to use it as a marinade
for this is because I'm searing that shrimp
and I don't want the herbs to burn, right?
I wanna keep that vibrancy.
Don't let the herbs burn!
(laughs) Drew, you should have water right beside you.
Yes, I do!
And so we're making a little bit of a pan sauce
and I'm gonna pour that in-
All the water?
Let's do half of that water
for now.
Half!
(laughs) I really like this, this call and repeat thing.
It's kind of what we do in our own kitchen.
And you're basically gonna let that go and cook down.
Two minutes.
I'm gonna give it a quick taste.
This really is Pilar and I in the kitchen.
She's casual and I look nuts.
(Pilar laughs)
This is so true to our life.
So maybe give your sauce
a little bit of a quick taste, Drew.
And I'm gonna add a little bit of lemon juice on there.
Lemon juice in the shrimp.
Got it.
Just a little bit.
Oh my God.
All right.
Now we're plating.
Whoa! I was not expecting
that much punch.
I'm gonna turn that off.
So right at this point, Drew,
the couscous-
Whoa!
(Pilar laughs)
Sorry, but like, wow.
Wow. In a good way?
Yes.
All right.
So the couscous is all steamed
and you're gonna fluff it with a fork.
And the reason why I like to use a fork
is because then it doesn't mush things up.
Yeah, don't use a spoon.
Don't use a spoon.
It will crush
all the tiny balls.
Look how fluffy that is!
Beautiful.
And nobody wants that.
One minute left.
We're plating up, Drew.
(Drew yells)
We got this!
Chill. It's nice.
It's chill. It's easy.
How you doing Drew?
You know what?
I'm doing really good.
You doing good?
Yeah. Actually.
And then basically, please do not
forget all that beautiful sauce that you worked so hard on.
You, son of a...
You got this.
Yah huh.
Oh, okay.
I'm doing like a thing
where I'm getting the sauce all over the thing.
And then, and then I'm gonna do my shrimp
'cause I know it's gonna splatter everywhere.
And plating is a part of my important,
like I take pride in my plating.
I take a lot of pride in my plating.
That looks beautiful.
Oh my, 50 seconds. Aaah!
And then don't forget to dollop your fresh chermoula.
Whoo!
There's no one right away.
(audience applauds)
We did it!